Ja. Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Guten Tag. Wer sind Sie denn bitte?
Ich bin Al-Shajtirik. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz-Hersin tätig
und würde gerne mit Ihnen heute das an einem Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Ich wollte da zum Herrn Müller. Wo ist der Herr Müller, bitte?
Herr Müller ist jetzt in Urlaub.
Ich bin Vertreter.
Ach so? Ja.
Also eigentlich wollte ich zum Herrn Dr. Müller. Man hat mir gesagt, der ist hier.
Ich wusste jetzt.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Man wollte immer die gleiche Arzt besuchen.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Aber ich kann auch Ihnen helfen.
Das ist kein anderer Arzt.
Leider. Leider heute gibt es nur ich.
Nur Sie? Oh je.
Na dann, okay. Wie ist Ihr Name, bitte?
Mein Name ist Ceyric.
Ist das ein ausländischer Name, oder?
Woher kommt der?
Ja, wir haben recht.
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Aus der Türkei? Ja.
Aber ich habe deutsche Approbation.
Ach so, ja dann.
Okay, wenn es sich anders geht, dann muss man das wohl so machen.
Okay, sollen wir anfangen?
Ja, bitte, bitte.
Ja, darf ich zuerst Ihren Name erfahren?
Mein Name ist Wolfgang Schüßler.
Ja, Herr Schüßler.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Ich dachte, Sie haben diese Angaben.
Muss ich das nochmal sagen?
Das habe ich davorhin schon bei der Anmeldung abgegeben.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben am Computer gespeichert,
aber ich muss nochmal fragen.
Noch mal.
Was ist das für ein komisches Krankenhauschen?
Meine Güte.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal mal geburtstaten.
Wie waren der nochmal?
23.
1968, 69.
69.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schüßler?
Ja, ist das jetzt wichtig?
Meine Güte, ich habe aber viele Fragen vor Ort,
ich habe ein Problem und ich stelle mich über meine Größe.
Was haben Sie, Herr Schüßler?
Ja, ich habe so einen großen Druck auf der Brust.
Es ist richtig eng und es ist keine Luft.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Enge für den Brustkorb?
Seit halber Stunde, um mir zu fehlen.
Das ist nicht mehr auszuhalten, diese Schmerzen,
das ist ganz schlimm.
Sind die Schmerzen?
Jetzt wird sie ganz schlimm.
Ach, ihr.
Ja, Sie haben im Brustkorb eine Enge geführt,
drücken die Schmerzen seit einer halben Stunde.
Ganz schlimm ist es im Moment.
Frau Dr. Ohr, das ist jetzt aber ganz schlimm.
Ohne die Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen ist drückend, ich verstehe.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Sparra?
Ganz schlimm im Moment, ganz schlimm.
Ganz schlimm, ich verstehe.
Ach, dem Sie mal bemerken, das ist ganz schlimm im Moment.
Das ist furchter, das kann das tun.
Ich verstehe, strahlende Schmerzen, irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, so im Halsbereich, das ist alles so eng im Hals.
Mhm.
Auch in den Armen oder in den Käfer?
Mehr in den Rücken, also strahlt mir eher in den Rücken aus.
In den Rücken aus, okay.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen für die Öztöge aufgetreten?
Frau Dr. Ohr, keine Luft, Frau Dr. Ohr, bitte.
Ja, Herr Schüster, so.
Jetzt muss ich das Geschenk aufrechnen
und wir müssen Ihre Vitalparameter prüfen.
Und ich gebe Ihnen Sauerstoff.
Sie würden sich besser fühlen.
Ich hoffe auch, bitte machen Sie.
Ich gebe Krankenschwester und wir geben Ihnen Sauerstoff.
Bitte, Frau Dr. Ohr, jetzt wird es schlimm.
Ja, Sie können jetzt hier hinlegen.
Ich falle jetzt um mich gleich bewusst los.
Ich gebe Ihnen Sauerstoff
und das wir Ihnen auch geben.
Und sofort, wir müssen eine EKG veranlassen.
Frau Dr. Ohr, was meinen Sie?
Was habe ich denn, was ist denn das, Frau Dr. Ohr?
Ich glaube, das ist eine Vermutung.
Sie haben einen Herzinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt, ach, gut, jetzt.
Es kann sein.
Aber das ist ganz gefährlich sein.
Oh, ich habe doch jetzt,
ich habe immer gesund gelebt.
Ich habe einen Herzinfarkt.
Ja, okay.
Frau Dr. Ohr, jetzt wird es ganz schlimm.
Ich bekomme keine Luft.
Ich gebe Ihnen Sauerstoff.
Fürdern Sie sich nicht besser?
Nein, das wird nicht besser.
Das wird jetzt ganz schlimm.
Okay.
Was kann ich noch sagen?
Ich denke an Pulmon de Rémbo,
aber ich weiß nicht, was ich anbieten kann.
Haben Sie ein Buch, das Sie EKG schreiben wollen?
Ja, ich habe es geschrieben.
Herr Dr. Günditz, wo ist der Kardäologin?
Was sehen wir in EKG?
Auf EKG können wir ST-Hebungen,
ST-Verhandlungen, können wir sagen.
ST-Hebungen,
das bedeutet, dass wir auf der ST-Heben.
Das kann sein.
Wenn Sie einen Herzinfarkt haben,
wir können auf EKG sehen
und wir können Sie sofort behandeln
mit Sauerstoff und Moffin
und Aspirin behandeln.
Aber ich will mir nichts zu haben.
Dann geben Sie mir Moffin.
Ja, ich habe sofort gegeben.
Jetzt wird es ein bisschen besser.
Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank, Frau Dr.
Jetzt geht es mir schon viel besser.
Ihre Vitalparameter wird besser.
Ist jetzt am Monitor.
Jetzt können wir unser Gespräch weitermachen.
Bitte.
Herr Schüster,
haben Sie wichtige Vorerkrankungen
und haben Sie schon mal diese Beschwerde erlebt?
Das habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Das ist das erste Mal.
Hatten Sie noch andere wichtige Vorerkrankungen?
Ich habe nicht nur einen hohen Blutdruck, sonst nichts.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter Bluthochdruck?
Seit circa 10 Jahren.
Nehmen Sie etwas dagegen ein?
Ja, ich habe Medikamente in meinem Haushalt.
Ich habe mir die Tabletten aufgeschrieben.
Könnten Sie die Namen der Tabletten erinnern?
Ich glaube, es nennt sich Rameprin.
Wie oft nehmen Sie Rameprin ein?
Einmal am Morgen eine Tablette.
50 Milligramm?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Haben Sie Ihre Medikamentenliste dabei?
Wir können anschauen.
Ich habe alles zu Hause vergessen.
Ich verstehe.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Ich habe noch etwas gegen das Cholesterin.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Das nennt sich, glaube ich, Atorvastatin.
Wie oft nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Eine am Abend, bevor ich schlafen will.
Ich glaube, 40 Milligramm.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Cholesterin?
Das ist schon länger.
Mehr als 10 Jahre.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nur am Knie.
Ich habe es schon seit 10 Jahren.
Ich habe es schon seit 10 Jahren operiert.
Nur am Knie, weil ich da so ein Kreuzband habe.
Wann haben Sie diese Medikamente erlitten?
Da war ich 20 Jahre alt.
Da waren Sie 20 Jahre alt.
Wurden Sie operiert?
Keine Operationen?
Sind Sie etwas allergisch?
Ich habe einige Allergien.
Ich habe eine Alergie gegen Pinzeline.
Wie euch erzielt diese Allergie?
Ich bekomme immer einen Ausschlag.
Und andere Allergie?
Gegen Neuergien.
Wie euch erzielt diese Allergie auch?
Ich bekomme Ausschlag, Luftnot und Kreislauf geht kaputt runter.
Okay, verstehe.
Herr Schüssler, in Ihrer Familie gibt es etwas Wichtige
Vorerkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte.
Bei Ihrer Mutter, bei Ihrer Frau?
Meine Eltern.
So weit ich weiß nicht.
Meine Mutter ist gesund, sie hat keine Tabletten.
Wie alt ist sie?
Sie ist 84.
Mein Vater nimmt etwas gegen die Prostata.
Wie alt ist sie?
Sie ist 86.
Ich habe eine Schwesterin.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, nicht schon ganz.
Sie hat auch einige Erkrankungen.
Sie ist ca. 8 Jahre älter als ich.
Sie hatte Diabetes, so weit ich war.
Und hatte irgendwo eine Erkrankung.
Sie hatte etwas mit der Brust.
Ich glaube, ein Knoten an der Brust.
Sie ist operiert worden.
Dann hat sie viele verschiedene Operationen.
Aber die weiß ich nicht mehr.
Herr Schüssler, ich möchte über Ihr Familienstand erfahren.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Was hat das mit der heutigen Unterdrückung?
Ich möchte wissen, wie Sie zusammen mit dem Wohnen leben.
Was geht es mit dem?
Nach der Entlassung von Krankenhaus.
Wir möchten Ihre Hausatmosphäre wissen.
Warum?
Das hat Sie doch nicht interessiert.
Was geht es mit dem?
Das ist für uns wichtig.
Wir werden Ihnen ein paar Medikamente geben.
Wir werden Ihnen zur Kontrolle rufen.
Vielleicht brauchen Sie jemanden.
Das kann ich alles alleine machen.
Super.
Ich verstehe.
Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 geimpft?
Nein, ich habe alles abgelehnt.
Ich will keine Impfung.
Sind Sie schon mal Covid-Erkrankt?
Nein, ich trage immer eine Maske.
Ich war verschont.
Ich habe bis jetzt keine Corona-Infektion.
Herr Schüssler, rufen Sie?
Ich habe früher geraucht.
Wann haben Sie mit dem Rachen aufgehört?
Zirka vor fünf Jahren.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Sehr lange.
Ich habe 15 Jahre eingefallen.
Etwa 40 Jahre.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie geraucht?
Schon eine Schachtlampe.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol.
Aber zumal ich es nicht.
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Wie viele Trinken haben Sie?
Ein Glas Wein.
Ein Glas Rotwein.
Das trink ich sehr gerne.
Ich habe noch nicht mehr.
Was denken Sie denn hier?
Herr Schüssler, möchten Sie etwas über Ihre Beschwerde erzählen?
Herr Schüssler, möchte ich etwas über Ihre Beschwerde erzählen?
Ich habe einen Druck gefühlt.
Das schnürt mir.
Sind diese Beschwerden ein bisschen besser geworden?
Nach Ihrer Spritze ist es besser geworden.
aber ich denke, es kommt wieder langsam.
Ja, Sie werden überwacht. Wir sind hier, da machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Ich glaube, dass wir alles gesprungen haben. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, bitte, gucken Sie, dass ich schnell die Schmerzen muss bekommen.
Also, das macht man jetzt, werde ich hier nur überwacht oder bekommt ich nicht mehr?
Sie werden überwacht und wir werden erfahren, ob es eine wichtige Gefäßproblem bei Ihnen gibt.
Ja, gucken Sie das?
Wir werden eine Herz-Uftrasche, Epokariografie durchführen und bei Bedarf, wir werden eine Herz-Katheteriangeografie bei Ihnen durchführen.
Was ist das? Ein Herz-Katheter?
Eine Operation oder was?
Eine kleine Operation kann man sagen, aber die Komplikationen sind sehr niedlich.
Eine Operation verdockt, nein.
Aber das kann webensbedrohlich sein, Ihre Situation.
Nein, nein, nein, ich möchte keine Operation verdockt, nein.
Okay, ich...
Ich will eine Operation abschreiten.
Rufen Sie mir den Oberarzt, ich glaube, Sie verstehen Ihr Werk nicht, Sie können das nicht so.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihnen sehr gut, aber es wäre am besten, wenn ich mit meinem Oberarzt wieder sprechen und...
Welchen, rufen Sie den Oberarzt?
Okay, warten Sie hier bitte.
Okay.
Ich denke, das ist gut für die Frau.
Sind Sie der Oberarzt? Guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend.
Sind Sie der Herzspezialist?
Dieser Doktor sagt, ich soll operiert werden. Was ist das für eine Operation?
Diese Operation ist nicht eine kleine Eingriff.
So können am besten herausfinden, ob sich mit ihren Herzgefälschen etwas verändert hat.
Und wie macht man diesen Eingriff?
Wenn es eine Verwendung oder Verschluße gibt, legen wir einen Stand und damit das Blut wieder ins Herzgefälschen kann.
Wir müssen eine kleine Schnitt in die Hand gelenkt machen.
Eine kleine Funktion.
Sie führen ein bisschen kein Problem.
Funktion macht dann in Ordnung. Eine Operation will ich aber nicht.
Keine Operation.
Gut, dass Sie da sind. Die andere Frau Doktor hat Sie nicht verstanden, die gesagt hat, ich soll operiert werden.
Ich habe eine sehr flüssige Assistenz und eine erfahrene Erstin.
Sie haben neue Deutsch gelern, aber gut.
Wenn Sie das als Oberarzt sagen, dann ist das in Ordnung, aber dann soll sie noch ein bisschen besser Deutsch lernen.
Wir haben unsere Eingriff-Labor erstellt und sofort zusammen eine Eingriff machen.
Herr Herzkatheter, da bin ich dabei.
Sehr gut, das ist ein guter Arzt.
Dann machen Sie das bitte ganz schnell.
Vielen Dank, Herr Herzkatheter.
Viele Fragen sind fertig, aber diese Situation ist sehr gut.
Öbelkeit, Erbüchern, Schweißigkeit müssen wir fragen.
Aber diese Situation ist eine gute Reaktion.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Wie würden Sie es mal beschreiben?
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe schon ein paar Fragen aufgenommen.
Ich möchte erklären, was der Patient hat.
Der Patient hat eine Arterellehypertone seit zehn Jahren.
Er hat eine Arterellehypertone seit zehn Jahren.
Der Patient ist nicht geimpft gegen Covid.
Der Patient hat vor fünf Jahren mit dem Rachen aufgehört.
Aber früher hat er etwa 30 Jahre einen Schachterl pro Tag geraucht.
Jeden Abend trinkte der Patient Alkohol, ein Glas Wein, hat er gesagt.
Er hat eine Art Erleichterung.